LOUISVILLE, $25 MILLION TO FIGHT
ASIAN CARP AND WESTERN KENTUCKY
AND BENEFITS FOR COAL MINERS.
AMERICANS COLLECTIVELY OWE ABOUT
ONE AND A HALF TRILLION DOLLARS
IN STUDENT LOANS, MORE THAN
TWICE THE TOTAL A DECADE AGO.
THE BURDEN WEIGHS ON MILLIONS OF
ADULTS IMPACTING LIFE CHOICES
AND OFTEN STUNTING FINANCIAL
GROWTH.
ONE SENATOR HAS AN IDEA TO HELP
BORROW FROM 401(K) RETIREMENT
PLANS.
CORRESPONDENT MARK MEREDITH
LOOKS AT THE PROPOSAL AND
POTENTIAL ISSUES.
>> THIS IS A BIG BURDEN.
>> RAND PAUL SAYS TOO MANY
AMERICANS ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
DOWN COLLEGE DEBT WHICH IS WHY
HE HAS INTRODUCED THE HELPER
ACT.
A BILL TO LET PEOPLE WITHDRAW
$5,250 FROM THEIR RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS ANNUALLY TAX AND
PENALTY FREE TO REDUCE COLLEGE
LOANS.
>> WE THINK IT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY TRANSFORM THE WAY
COLLEGE IS PAID FOR IN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> PAUL SAYS WITH MORE COMPANIES
MATCHING 401(K) CONTRIBUTIONS
EVEN AMERICANS ON SMALLER
INCOMES ARE SAVING MONEY.
HE SAYS LETTING PEOPLE REDUCE
DEBT NOW CREATES OPPORTUNITIES
TO SAVE MORE IN THE FUTURE.
>> IT DOESN'T WORK UNLESS YOU
PUT ASIDE SAVINGS.
>> CRITICS SAY THE IDEA ONLY
HELPS A CERTAIN CLASS.
>> IT WOULD BE A WIN FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A LOT OF MONEY AND TAKE
AN EXTRA TAX BREAK BY INVESTING
IN THE 401(K) FIRST AND THEN
TAKING IT OUT TAX FREE BUT THOSE
ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T ACTUALLY
STRUGGLE WITH STUDENT DEBT.
>> FINANCIAL EXPERTS WARNED
RETIREMENT ACCOUNT WITHDRAWALS
DO COME WITH A CERTAIN COST.
>> WE DO SEND THE MESSAGE THAT
IT'S BEST IF YOU LEAVE THAT
MONEY UNTAPPED AND INVESTED IN
THE LET IT HOPEFULLY BENEFIT
FROM GROWTH.
>> THE SENATE IS ALSO PROPOSING
TO LET PARENTS WITHDRAW
RETIREMENT MONIES TEXT THE
MEANING OF PARENT WITH TWO
INCOMES WOULD ALLOW FOR LOANS
TAX-FREE EACH YEAR.
HE HAS REACHED OUT TO SOME
DEMOCRATS TO BUILD SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND HE HOPES MORE
STUDENTS WILL SPEAK UP TO
PRESSURE LAWMAKERS TO CREATE
MORE WAYS TO REDUCE THE BURDEN
OF COLLEGE DEBT.